how he has
Oh
he has published on his entra nella see
environment he it's a newsletter of the
lse central for environmental policy and
governance he wrote the beginner's guide
to platos the Republic he was born in
London I won't say the year he has
degrees and diplomas from campus
University Barcelona university and the
lse he's a journalist as I say he writes
the he established and writes the FT
slow lane column and was a theater
critic wine editor of harbin Queens wine
columnist for The Spectator and the
first one so far the only poetry editor
of The Daily Express oh yes and thank
you so you you can probably see that I'm
not against all technology particularly
not winemaking but um I think we've got
to be quite as precise hear what I'm
going to argue is that certain kinds of
new technology may be causing more
serious problems and remember the
serious bit and then they're solving
because first were deeply confused about
technology or about the essence of
technology as the philosopher Heidegger
put it come back to him and secondly
because we're confused about what
constitutes a problem and were overly
addicted to the whole paradigm of
problem solving now I'm going to take
the the second prong of that pitch book
first pitch fork another very good old
technology very useful for different
kinds of things and I want to question
this whole mindset of problem solving
and I suggested a problem solving
mentality which sees problems everywhere
and maybe even creates them where they
don't exist and also tends to see them
in isolation not connected to anything
else by the way you're not going to get
an anti green tirade from me rather the
opposite but I'll come back that now
there are some things which may well be
problems which are amenable to solution
how to drill teeth without causing pain
for example and you certainly won't find
me advocating a return to medieval
dentistry
and that could be multiplied all sorts
of things along those lines but we
should be very careful about what we see
as a problem and I want to take
communication and this has already come
up and that's going to come up more i'm
sure and communications technologies
partly because that's an area where
technology is proliferating and new
technologies particularly proliferating
and also because that's an area where
this problem solving mentality maybe
especially misguided so a question is
human communication exactly a problem
which can be solved or to put it another
way what would happen if it were solved
the implication of problem solving is
that the problem dissolves or disappears
in the solution but what a terrible
thing would be of human communication
dissolved in the solution and that may
sound sort of a far-fetched or
apocalyptic but mobile phones and emails
and maybe Twitter and other things which
promise better communication or
according to orange a whole new concept
of communication may also be complicit
in doing away with communication in any
profound sense all together and here is
a and here's here is a vision from an
orange press release this is of a
communication device and now I quote
perhaps as small as a stud in your ear
eventually you will simply say what you
want whenever you want it and wherever
you want it is that communication I mean
communication it except maybe for a tiny
baby or possibly a looter sorry to say
that it's not just about saying what you
want the another journal philosopher
habermas defines communication while
more generously as mutual understanding
in language email by the way I use these
technologies or they use me that's not
quite sure which
I have a mobile phone I don't know it's
a good thing I used email that email
together with other disembodied
communications technologies promises a
kind of instant and unfettered
communication it promises to dispense
with tedious formalities at the same
time as it vastly speeds up the process
process of delivery now this site this
sounds wonderful but it also introduces
a whole new set of problems with some of
them may be serious how do you address
recipients of emails how do you sign off
I think this is a tremendous problem but
this is this terrible uneasiness in the
absence of etiquette with email I find
and even worse than that emails are just
too easy to send and no thought was
given by the inventors of email whoever
they were I don't know who they were to
the effect of being bombarded with
communication in this way and the
horrible feeling of not being able to
respond now responsible communication
and responsible communications
technology I think must include
awareness of the possibility or
impossibility of response responses is
key to others and of course it is not
just a technological problem also an
ethical problem now let me just assert
something human communication is thick
and slow and should remain so it is
thick with irreducible human elements
elements of character emotion address
courtesy tone any new communications
technology which promises to do away
with this irreducible thickness and
slowness turning communications into a
sort of into sorry into a set of
disembodied and perhaps ultimately
financial transactions is likely to
cause more serious problems than it
solves and I think it looks as if the
same could be said about technologies
which promised to do away with the
irreducible thicknesses and
interconnectedness a--'s of nature so
I'm not singing from the same song she
is Brendan on this point um new fishing
technologies for example which I'm sure
he would he would praise but we agree on
those things but not on this I just on
the cut because I don't everyone's
really elated you might be remotely
agree but no new fishing technologies
and which appear to solve problems like
how to catch more haddock or cod end
England whole marine environment and
also destroying stocks of Huracan cod
serious problems so I'm coming back now
to the first confusion or the confusion
about the essence of Technology now I
think we think of technologies as means
two ends in other words thoroughly
instrumental but the trouble was that is
that if everything as a means to an end
and I think we can include most new
technologies under that then the end
somehow gets lost along the way I'm
going to sprint racing but under this
way of thinking which Heidegger called
in framing we have brought about a
nightmare in which everything is a means
to an end a resource the river is not a
river but of power source we ourselves
and the current management jargon are
not human beings but human resources but
in its origins this is a to think about
as i finish technology is not a means
this is what Heidegger says it but it's
a way of revealing even a way of
revealing the truth the Greek word techn
a means both technique and art
you'll have to be your grilling from
here because you don't have time for you
to go back there it's I say we I just
make sure you speak into the mic okay
first your witness Harry just just tell
me one thing you're saying that the
world would be a better place without
mobile phones and emails you if you add
your magic wand you'd wave it they
disappear we'd all be happier is that
right I'm not saying that I didn't say
that I'm saying that they're just
joining up the dots that's all I'm doing
yeah i mean i'm deeply divided in myself
about whether the mobile is a good thing
or a bad thing i did know be honest in
my own case I've resisted having one
you've invested your own money in modern
technology I guess I shame on you you
have to be you know you're my side
obviously well I know I use these things
but with weariness and with some doubt
about what they might be doing both to
me and two other people I can't draw
them all together why I could but I'm
not going to end living in a cave all of
build a cabin and Walden Pond I really
wish I could but I'm not that kind of
person I'm part of the modern world but
I'm weary and practically